uh it's great to see both of you uh on
zoom as usual and i will just say that
uh congrats on the movie um for both of
you i've spoken to a lot of actors and
they talk about when they
are nervous about a role that's when
they want they gravitate towards it it's
they want to you know that they want to
do it um is it the same for both of you
i mean because i would imagine this
project is so different than anything
else you've read
absolutely i mean i i feel like i can
speak for both of us when i say that
like there's nothing more exciting than
the feeling of almost like
can i do this like can i really do this
you know am i you know what i mean like
i i think that there's nothing more
exciting than uh something that poses a
real challenge and a challenge that
you've like never been faced with before
um and this was definitely that for me
yeah i completely agree i think you you
get really inspired by the challenge
um and and all the possibilities of it
uh yeah are what kind of drew us through
us both to it i think
i'm a big fan of terry notary and i know
you guys worked with him uh i would
imagine that he
talk a little bit about working with him
and did he sort of give you that
confidence of really just going for it
totally and i think what i what i really
didn't expect about i mean i i was
really excited about the prospect of
working with terry as well i'm a huge
fan of his work and i just think he's
like you know so insanely talented in a
very kind of unique way that's so
specific to him and and uh i think what
i wasn't expecting um you know about the
the working with terry is it's just how
emotional that it would be and how much
it would help me in my emotional
connection to the character as well as
just like getting the physical you know
animal stuff down it was it really
helped me connect to her
her emotional side and and uh and feel
free you know in my funneling my own
emotion into that and you know i was
surprised at how much i cried you know
during the during the work sessions with
him because it just it just gets you to
this place where you're um
i don't know you just it's like almost
like a like it's almost like a
meditative state where you just feel
very connected to your body and your
emotions and you are so free of like any
sort of judgment towards yourself or and
almost like free of you know thought and
like you're you're kind of just like
letting whatever happens uh happen and
and that that was a very kind of
precious state to find myself in and and
a really cool place to like create from
i think
yeah i again i completely agree i think
terry was profound like the work that he
does
and as well his scene from the square is
like
you know that's that's a shining example
of when someone commits to a to a choice
and how affecting it is like when
especially when it's something kind of
out there
um
but
yeah and like lily said there was so
much so much of the subtleties that
terry unlocked were the things that were
kind of massive for the characters like
this just a simple thing that before we
found the individual animals it was like
okay well what is wild what is most
natural and therefore that's a step away
from what is being human and we found
that kind of humanity is thought it's
all the thoughts that we have and all
the voices that kind of like dictate
your movements or judge or or kind of
commenting on yourself all the time and
to be without that was kind of
such a simple discovery but such a
profound discovery into the
understanding of someone who identifies
as or who is an animal but just in the
body of a man
um the first scene where you guys meet
is
really cool there's no dialogue if you
guys as your animals
you know discovering each other i would
imagine talk a little bit about filming
that scene because i i don't know how
that can be scripted you know i would
imagine that must be found in the
rehearsal process and maybe a little bit
on set
yeah i mean that one was a really
special one and we spoke a little bit
about this earlier but it was like you
know that scene kind of became the basis
for a lot of our uh
exploration of our characters dynamic um
because we kind of used it in like to do
all these animal improvs together and it
took on a lot of like it went through a
lot of different forms before it became
like what's on screen um
and and so that was kind of like yeah
served as our as our kind of like
playground for finding you know how
these characters interact as animals
which is which is you know
in the place that we meet them in the
movie that's that's where they feel the
most themselves that's where they feel
the most comfortable and the most free
and the most connected to themselves and
so to each other and so it was really
important to kind of um
yeah find that find that dynamic within
within that movement and uh and and
shooting it it almost i feel like became
this sort of like
like this sort of like ballet almost we
were like kind of like describing it
like that
yeah it's that again that was that's one
of my favorite favorite scenes in in the
film to do and and in the in the final
piece as well and as lily said it became
because it is so
uh it's you know it was it was
choreographed but to find that
choreography that we then sort of
improvised a little in you know in the
doing of it
there was um
you know the journey of rehearsing that
you go through as lily said all the
different dynamics of the character like
what if we play with this part of like
kind of their their dynamic or what if
we
sort of make it more if it's a sort of
sensual energy or what if it's a more of
a kind of playful energy and uh and just
sort of exploring those over time kind
of you know we found things that if we
didn't use it in that moment definitely
kind of then got used at another place
within the story
i know you guys were getting ready to
film and then covet struck and then you
had months of down time before you
started shooting i would imagine that
what is that like as an actor building
up to that moment where you're going to
do a role like this and then okay now
let's just pause and spend a bunch of
time thinking about it until we may or
may not be doing it well yeah there was
there was an interesting and i was
saying this earlier but there's there's
an interesting kind of parallel where i
mean first of all you know i
it was an opportunity to just keep
prepping and keep practicing and i think
you know that can you know as much as
like there were a lot of obviously
negative parts of that period of time
that you know that can never be a bad
thing is having more time to you know
delve deeper into the exploration of
your character and your prep time you
know that's never gonna be time wasted
um and i think there was an also like a
strange parallel with how we were all
like locked in our houses and there was
a growing almost like fear of the
outside world and like feeling like it
was dangerous out there and we were like
scared to go outside and everything um
that was paralleled with i think how the
characters feel how a lot of the
characters feel uh in the story and
specifically my character because she's
been there for so long and she's so
sheltered and this clinic is kind of the
only world that she knows and she like
is very scared of the outside world and
and doesn't really have the tools to
survive out there and so i think there
was like an interesting parallel there
as well
i i think it's well did just the
physical side of things as well is that
there was going to be that we had a
week's kind of workshopping to begin to
find the animals then we were going to
have two weeks off then we were going to
come together as a company and and do
three weeks rehearsal and then shoot the
film and it was in that two weeks that
the kind of respective lockdowns
happened and the film got pushed
but that said like what we found in that
first week
i don't know if we could have done it in
the same way having had a fortnight of
practice because the sort of two and a
half months that came in between to
crawl every day and
for suddenly
like it's so important especially for
jacob as well that he feels most
comfortable on all fours and it's just
in a kind of literally to have not had
your body been in that position
ever before
it took the time to kind of like you
know to get the muscle memory to feel to
feel good in that place
i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
seriously i thought you both did such a
great job in this i wish you nothing but
the best and good luck with the rest of
your speed dating thank you so much